>> THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER.
THANK YOU, EVERYONE, FOR FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY.
UM, AS YOU SEE, WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITOL.
I WANT TO ASK ALL MEMBERS WHO
ARE LISTENING OR IN
THEIR ROOMS TO PLEASE COME TO
ROOM 113, ROOM 113.
HOWEVER, WE DO HAVE A QUORUM,
SO I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
>> RUBIO.
I I'M SORRY.
PRESENT.
RUBIO.
MILO.
PRESENT.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
PRESENT.
ALVARADO.
GIL.
PRESENT.
CABALLERO.
CORTEZ.
DODD.
OKOBO.
PRESENT.
SO NOW THAT WE HAVE EVERYONE
PRESENT,
I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE AUTHORS.
UNFORTUNATELY, SO VERY RARE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM WITHOUT THE
AUTHORS.
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY.
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE.
UM, THEY SAID THEY'RE ON THEIR
WAY,
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO TAKE A
FIVE MINUTE PAUSE.
OKAY.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE WILL NOW
RECONVENE.
I SEE WE HAVE OUR AUTHOR HERE,
MR.
ALVAREZ.
PLEASE JOIN US.
AND, UH, UM, YOUR WITNESS CAN
ALSO JOIN YOU IN THE FRONT.
WE ALREADY OPENED AND
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM.
SO WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY
PROCEED PRESENTING.
AB 2996.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2996.
I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF AND
YOURSELF FOR THE WORK.
MADAM CHAIR, ON THIS BILL, AB
2996 WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE FAIR PLAN TO
REQUEST
THAT THE EYE BANK ISSUE BONDS
TO ENHANCE
THE SOLVENCY OF THE FAIR PLAN,
AND AUTHORIZES THE EYE BANK TO
USE TO ISSUE THOSE BONDS.
UH, THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S,
UH, RELATIVELY NEW FOR ME,
BUT A CRISIS IN THE ENTIRE
STATE.
I THINK WE'VE ALL HEARD THE
STORIES FROM
OUR OWN CONSTITUENTS ON
INSURANCE.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF YOU HAVE
DONE
A LOT OF WORK ON THAT FRONT.
SO WE THANK YOU.
UH, PARTICULAR CONCERN TO ME
WAS WHEN
I'M FOCUSED A LOT ON HOUSING
AND OUR HOUSING CRISIS AND
TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THAT.
AND IN MY OWN BACKYARD IN OTAY
MESA COMMUNITY THAT
I REPRESENT AND HAD THE HONOR
OF REPRESENTING,
UH, NOW GOING ON TEN YEARS
PREVIOUSLY
ON THE CITY COUNCIL,
WHERE WE ACTUALLY ZONED FOR
A LOT OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS,
WHICH IS WHAT WE WANT.
UH, ONE OF OUR HOUSE BUILDERS,
UH,
OUR CONSTRUCTION COMPANY THAT
WAS TRYING
TO BUILD SOME HOUSING UNITS,
UH, RAN INTO A PROBLEM WHEN IT
CAME TO INSURANCE.
AND SO THAT IS HOW MY INTEREST
SORT OF
CAME TOGETHER ON THESE TWO
CRISES
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS
HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE, IN OUR
STATE.
UM, THIS IN PARTICULAR, UH,
ISSUE,
I WAS ENCOURAGED TO SEE THE
DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE AND THE FAIR PLAN
ASSOCIATION
ANNOUNCED LAST YEAR.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, THE $20 MILLION
PER LOCATION
VERSUS 20 MILLION PER STRUCTURE,
UH, APPROACH, WHICH IS NOW BEING
TAKEN,
WHICH I THINK WILL BE HELPFUL.
AND THIS IS CERTAINLY A MUCH
NEEDED STEP,
BUT IT ALSO PUTS AN ALREADY
OVEREXPOSED,
AS YOU KNOW, FAIR PLAN AT
A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL RISK.
IF THERE IS A MAJOR FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE COME IN WITH
THIS BILL,
OUR ATTEMPT,
OUR HOPE IS THAT THE MARKET
SEES THIS
AS A TOOL AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO USE IT,
BUT AVAILABLE TO THEM IN THE IN
THE SITUATION WHERE,
UM, THEY, WE ARE FIND OURSELVES
IN
AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION AND UM,
UH, A PAYMENT HAS TO BE MADE,
UM, ON THE OBLIGATIONS THAT,
UH, OCCUR AS A RESULT OF,
OF OF, OF A OF A DISASTER SUCH
AS A FIRE,
UH, WHERE THIS TOOL,
AGAIN, A TOOL, AN OPTION COULD
BE UTILIZED
ESSENTIALLY TO OVER THE COURSE
OF YEARS,
DECADES REALLY, AS OPPOSED TO
OVER THE COURSE OF DAYS, UM,
PAYMENT HAS TO BE MADE IN ORDER
TO COVER
THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ARE,
UM, UH, ENCUMBERED UPON BY,
BY THE PRIVATE MARKET INSURANCE
MARKET.
SO THIS DOES NOTHING TO RATES,
THIS DOES NOTHING,
WHICH WE KNOW THERE'S WORK TO
BE DONE
AND WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
AROUND THAT.
THIS IS REALLY TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO, AGAIN,
HOPEFULLY CREATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE
OF CERTAINTY AND AN ATMOSPHERE,
AS I THINK WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO DO,
OF TRYING TO MAINTAIN THE MARKET
STRONG
INSURERS TO STAY IN THE STATE
AND PROVIDE AN OPTION THAT STILL
THERE WILL BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE WILL, UH, ON ALL ON THE
BACKS OF INSURERS.
BUT THROUGH A VEHICLE, THIS TOOL
OF TRYING
TO AMORTIZE THOSE COSTS OVER
MULTIPLE
YEARS AS OPPOSED TO A BILL THAT
WOULD
THEY WOULD GET HIT WITH
IMMEDIATELY.
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
HOPING TO DO.
UM, AND I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
DAN DUNMYER
FROM THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION,
WHO IS MY WITNESS ON THIS?
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
DAN DONMOYER, PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
I JUST WANT TO THANK MR.
ALVAREZ FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE
AND JUST TO MOVE AND AMPLIFY
HIS COMMENT.
AS HE MENTIONED IN OTAY MESA,
THERE WAS A COUPLE
THOUSAND CONDOMINIUMS WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD.
THIS IS THE MOST ATTAINABLE
FOR SALE
HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT HALF THE PRICE OF THE
AVERAGE
COST OF A NEW HOME IN SAN DIEGO,
AND THIS IS REPEATED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
IT OCCURS IN THE NORTHERN PART
OF SAN DIEGO.
IT OCCURS IN LA, OCCURS IN
CENTRAL VALLEY,
OCCURS IN THE EAST BAY.
IT OCCURS IN SACRAMENTO.
ALL OF OUR CONDOMINIUMS.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
COVERAGE NEEDED,
IT'S CALLED COMMERCIAL INSURANCE
INSTEAD OF RESIDENTIAL
BECAUSE YOU'RE INSURING THE
ENTIRE ASSOCIATION.
AND AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID,
THE FAIR PLAN RIGHT NOW
DOESN'T ADDRESS MORE THAN 20
MILLION PER LOCATION.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO
MOVE IT TO 20 MILLION PER
BUILDING.
AND WITH THAT EXPANDED EXPOSURE,
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE FAIR PLAN CAN HANDLE A MAJOR
LOSS,
THE ANALYSIS SAYS.
SO ACCURATELY, THE FAIR PLAN IS
UP TO 336 BILLION IN EXPOSURE,
WITH 200 MILLION IN CAPACITY,
WHICH MAKES IT FISCALLY
QUESTIONABLE.
SO GIVING THE FAIR PLAN THIS
VOLUNTARY TOOL
TO HAVE AS A BACKSTOP SHOULD A
FIRE IGNITE,
THAT BURNS DOWN A NUMBER OF
HOMES THAT
ARE INSURED BY THE FAIR PLAN.
THEY HAVE THIS TOOL, TWO PIECES
OF HISTORY HERE.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN
AROUND A WHILE,
NOT THE FIRST TIME WE'VE DONE
THIS,
THIS COMMITTEE BACK IN 2002 WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN VARGAS,
NOW CONGRESSMAN VARGAS PASSED
A NEARLY IDENTICAL MEASURE
THAT ALLOWED FOR A BACKSTOP
FINANCIAL MECHANISM FOR
THE WORKERS COMP SYSTEM WHEN IT
RAN INTO BANKRUPTCY
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
DEREGULATED THE COMP MARKET.
SO THIS HAS BEEN TRIED AND
TESTED
VIA THE THE EYE BANK.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THIS
IS, MR.
ALVAREZ NOTED, IS IN THAT CASE,
THE CONSUMERS POLICYHOLDERS
PAID A $10 A YEAR SURCHARGE
AND THIS BILL 100% OF THE COST
OF REPAYMENT,
AS WELL AS DEVELOPING THE BONDS,
IS BORNE SOLELY BY THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
THAT'S THE ONLY DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE TWO LAWS.
UM, LAST THING I WILL SAY.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
TAKEN ON JUNE 20TH.
THEY ADDRESSED THE ISSUES THAT
WERE IN THE ASSEMBLY,
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE RAISED BY
MISS CALDERON,
AN ISSUE ALSO RAISED ON
CLARIFYING WHAT
ACTUALLY IS A FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION.
WE ALSO ADDRESSED ISSUES BY THE
CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE,
WHO HAD QUESTIONS ABOUT USING
THE RIGHT
WORDS OF SOLVENCY VERSUS
CAPACITY.
WE ALSO TOOK CARE OF FAIR
PLAYING CONCERNS
ON DEFINING BOTH THE CONCEPT
OF A BOND,
BUT ALSO ADDRESSING THE ISSUE
OF A SHORT
TERM BRIDGE LOAN OR LINE OF
CREDIT.
AND THE FINAL THING IS TECHNICAL
ISSUES.
WE BROUGHT IN THE LEADING BOND
COUNSEL FOR
THE TREASURER AND THE EYE BANK
WORK,
AND THEY HAVE BEEN GIVING US
TECHNICAL
ADVICE ON HOW TO CRAFT THIS
TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTORS
WHO WOULD CONSIDER THIS.
SO THEY PROVIDE A BOND AT THE
LOWEST INTEREST RATE.
THOSE ARE THE FOUR CHANGES MADE
SINCE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
WE FEEL THIS IS A GOOD TOOL.
IT'S NOT JUST US AT CBI.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS,
THERE'S CLOSE TO 30 OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THIS.
THIS WORKS FOR REALTORS
APARTMENT OWNERS,
BUT ALSO WORKS FOR THE FARM
BUREAU.
IT WORKS FOR OTHER PARTIES THAT
ARE HAVE COMMERCIAL STRUCTURES,
NOT JUST US.
SO WE SEE THIS AS A SOLUTION,
UH,
AVAILABLE SOLUTION TO THE FAIR
PLAN.
AND WE WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YES, MA'AM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY.
SO NOW I WILL INVITE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT,
TO PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIC.
>> MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, CARLOS
GUTIERREZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE,
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
GRACE COPLAND HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> MARK SEGMENT WITH THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT, PLEASE COME UP.
OKAY, SO NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO JOIN ME.
SEEING NONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE ANY
MEMBER OF THE AUDIENCE TO
COME UP AND SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS MEASURE.
K SEEING NONE.
THAT WAS FAST.
I'M NOW INVITE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS.
OKAY, I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
SENATOR DODD.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T HAVE ANY, UH, CRITICISMS
OR ANYTHING.
>> OF THIS BILL.
I JUST APPLAUD THE OFFICE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THIS IS REALLY A COMMON.
SENSE BILL THAT SEEKS TO BE.
>> PROACTIVE.
HOPEFULLY WE DON'T NEED THIS,
BUT IF WE NEED IT, WE'VE GOT IT.
AND I JUST THINK IT'S A GREAT
BILL
TO BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK,
MR.
CORTESE?
I WOULD JUST ECHO THOSE SAME
REMARKS,
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS
COMING FORWARD WITH THIS.
BASED ON INFORMATION I THINK
SOME OF US HAVE AND UM,
GROUPS THAT WERE WORKING WITH
UM,
WERE PERHAPS A MAJOR FIRE OR
TWO AWAY
FROM A FAIR PLAN AND SOLVENCY.
SO I THINK THIS IS CRITICAL AND
THE TIMING
IS CRITICAL AND I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBER WISHING TO
SPEAK?
OKAY.
NONE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, DAN, THANK YOU.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN TACKLING THIS
HOUSING
ISSUE AND AND WE CONTINUE
TO WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
MORE HOUSING, MORE STOCK.
AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY GOING
TO HELP
US IN CALIFORNIA BRING DOWN
COSTS.
AND AND WE ARE STILL NOT QUITE
THERE BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE CAN'T GET INSURANCE.
SO THANK YOU.
AND TO MR.
ALVAREZ, I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED
HARD ON THIS AND YOU'VE TAKEN
A LOT OF AMENDMENTS AND TRYING
TO GET IT TO A GOOD PLACE.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR
TRYING TO BRING RELIEF TO THE
PLAN.
I KNOW THAT THAT'S A BIG
CONCERN.
AND, UM, THIS, UH, UM,
FINANCIAL MECHANISM WILL HELP.
SO WITH THAT, MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU.
OH, WAIT.
I'M SORRY.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
SO MOVED BY SENATOR ALVARADO.
GIL.
THANK YOU.
FILE ITEM TWO AB 2996 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
RUBIO I, RUBIO I NILO A NILO
I ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO.
GIL I CABALLERO CORTEZ I CORTEZ
I DODD I DODD I BOCOBO I.
THE EXISTENCE.
THIS MEASURE HAS A ZERO.
WE NEED TO LEAVE THE ROW OPEN
FOR THOSE THAT ARE ABSENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE'LL JUST LEAVE IT OPEN.
UM, WE'RE WAITING FOR OUR NEXT
AUTHOR.
WE DON'T SEE HIM CURRENTLY HERE.
IS THERE ANY MEMBER OF HIS STAFF
THAT WANTS TO PRESENT THE BILL?
OKAY, SO WE'LL TAKE A SHORT FIVE
MINUTE RECESS
UNTIL WE CAN GET THE NEXT AUTHOR
HERE.
THANK YOU.
THE SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WILL RECONVENE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY, FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
TODAY WE ARE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING AB
2416 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY.
AND WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU MAY
PROCEED.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
UH, I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR TIRELESS WORK
ON THIS BILL,
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
I'M PROUD TODAY TO PRESENT AB
2416,
A BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO REVIEW
AND CONSIDER UPDATES TO THE
SAFER
FROM WILDFIRE REGULATIONS
EVERY FIVE YEARS STARTING ON
JANUARY 1ST, 2030.
SPECIFICALLY, CDI, IN
CONSULTATION WITH CAL OES,
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING, RESEARCH
AND CAL FIRE,
WOULD CONSIDER IF ADDITIONAL
BUILDING HARDENING
MEASURES AND COMMUNITY LEVEL
WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PROGRAMS SHOULD BE
INCLUDED
IN THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS NEAR
AND DEAR
TO COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AS YOU ALL KNOW, WHERE WILDFIRE
RISKS ARE HIGH
AND INSURANCE IS INCREASINGLY
UNAFFORDABLE AND ABSENT.
MY DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY IS IN
A REGION THAT HAS EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE WORST WILDFIRES IN
RECENT HISTORY,
AND I'M CONSTANTLY TALKING TO
FOLKS WHO ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN WITH
THEIR
OWN MONEY TO PROTECT THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITIES FROM THE NEXT
DISASTER.
THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRES PROGRAM
IS
THE ONLY AVENUE OPEN TO
CONSUMERS TO
RECEIVE DIRECT DISCOUNTS FOR
HARDENING
THEIR HOMES AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
THESE INSURANCE DISCOUNTS ARE
A GREAT INCENTIVE,
AND IT COSTS THE STATE NOTHING
TO OFFER IT.
RIGHT NOW, THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT FOR CDI
TO OPEN UP THE REGULATIONS FOR
EVALUATION.
AS NEW AND SAFER BUILDING
MATERIALS COME TO MARKET
AND WILDFIRE PREVENTION METHODS
EVOLVE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
PERIODICALLY
REVISIT THE REGULATIONS AND
EVALUATE
IF THEY CAPTURE THE BEST
MITIGATION
PRACTICES AVAILABLE,
AND IF THE REGULATIONS ARE
OFFERING
MUCH AS MUCH RELIEF AS
POSSIBLE TO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING.
WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
INDUSTRY,
INCLUDING A THREE YEAR DELAY
FROM
THE ORIGINAL PROPOSAL TO ALLOW
FOR ONGOING EFFORTS TO SHORE UP
THE INSURANCE MARKET TO FINISH,
AND FOR CDI TO CLEAR ITS CURRENT
APPROVAL BACKLOG.
IN FACT, IN THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THIS BILL,
WE WERE SPECIFICALLY CALLING OUT
THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AS STAKEHOLDERS THAT
CDI MUST CONSULT
WITH WHEN REVIEWING THE
REGULATIONS.
WE HAVE ALSO WORKED TO ENSURE
THAT THERE
IS NO PROP 103 ISSUE WITH THIS
BILL.
AGAIN, ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
REQUIRE CDI TO PERIODICALLY
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THESE
REGULATIONS
NEED TO BE UPDATED TO REFLECT
THE FUTURE
NEEDS OF CONSUMERS AND THE
INDUSTRY.
THE FINAL SAY, AS ALWAYS, WILL
BE LEFT
WITH THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
SO TO WRAP UP, WHILE CDI WORKS
ON OTHER STRATEGIES
TO IMPROVE THE INSURANCE MARKET
IN CALIFORNIA,
AB 2416 IS A REASONABLE STEP
THE LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE
TO HELP CONSUMERS SAVE MONEY ON
THEIR INSURANCE
BILLS AND REDUCE THE RISK OF
DISASTER FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND THE FAMILIES
THAT LIVE THERE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON IS MELANIE
LAW WITH THE NORTH AMERICAN
INSULATION
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
JOEL LAUBSCHER
WITH UNITED POLICYHOLDERS.
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN COME TO THE FRONT.
YOUR MAIN WITNESS.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS LINDA BARRERA.
ON BEHALF OF THE NORTH AMERICAN
INSULATION MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
2416.
NEMA IS THE TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR NORTH
AMERICAN MANUFACTURERS OF
FIBERGLASS,
STONE, WOOL AND SLAG WOOL
INSULATION PRODUCTS.
AS PART OF OUR ROLE, WE SUPPORT
POLICIES THAT PROMOTE
PASSIVE FIRE PROTECTION
STRATEGIES IN WILDLIFE
URBAN INTERFACE AREAS TO HELP
REDUCE FIRE SPREAD
SEVERITY AND LOSS OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY.
AB 2416 WOULD REQUIRE, BY 2030,
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO
EVALUATE
WHETHER TO UPDATE THE SAFER
FROM WILDFIRE REGULATIONS AND
REQUIRE SUBSEQUENT
REVIEWS OF THE REGULATION EVERY
FIVE YEARS.
AS PART OF THESE ONGOING
REVIEWS,
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
WOULD DETERMINE
IF ADDITIONAL BUILDING HARDENING
MEASURES
AND COMMUNITY LEVEL WILDLIFE
MITIGATION
PROGRAMS WOULD BE ADOPTED TO
FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
TO
ADOPT HOME HARDENING MEASURES
THAT
WILL REDUCE THEIR WILDFIRE RISK.
THE FIRST EVALUATION WILL TAKE
PLACE SIX YEARS FROM NOW AS
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE
FIRST EVALUATION,
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO CONSIDER
INTEGRATING
FIRE SAFE BUILDING MATERIALS,
SUCH AS THOSE OF THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S
BUILDING MATERIAL LIST.
LISTING THESE FIRE SAFE BUILDING
MATERIALS ON THE BML,
BML HAVE ALL BEEN TESTED AND
CERTIFIED
BY THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
ACCREDITED LABORATORIES
FOR THEIR FIRE SAFETY
PERFORMANCE.
WE SUPPORT THE AUTHORS EFFORTS
TO ENCOURAGE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
TO ADD
FIRE PROTECTION BUILDING
MATERIALS TO
THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRE
REGULATIONS.
THIS WILL HELP ACCELERATE THE
ADOPTION OF BMI,
BMI CERTIFIED BUILDING MATERIALS
IN WILDFIRE PRONE AREAS.
REVIEWING THE SAFER FROM
WILDFIRE REGULATIONS
EVERY FIVE YEARS WILL GIVE
CONSUMERS,
FIRE SERVICE PROFESSIONALS AND
INSURANCE PROVIDERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EXAMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE REGULATIONS AND MAKE
NECESSARY CHANGES THAT
WILL FURTHER THE INTENT OF THE
REGULATIONS,
WHICH IS TO INCENTIVIZE
CONSUMERS
TO REDUCE THEIR WILDFIRE RISK.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE ENCOURAGE
YOUR
SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN.
THANK YOU.
NOW I WILL INVITE ANY MEMBER OF
THE AUDIENCE TO
COME AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
>> THEY HAVE ONE MORE.
OH, YOU HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS
IN SUPPORT.
OH, I'M SO SORRY.
YES.
PLEASE JOIN US.
MY APOLOGIES.
I THOUGHT HE MIGHT BE OPPOSING
THE BILL,
SO I WAS GOING TO GO TO THAT
NEXT.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS OF THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SENATOR DODD.
HELLO.
UH, THANK YOU FOR HAVING, UH,
CONSIDERING THIS BILL.
UH, MY NAME IS JOEL LAUCHER.
I AM HERE REPRESENTING UNITED
POLICYHOLDERS,
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT THAT WORKS
TO,
UH, BENEFIT INSURANCE CONSUMERS
IN
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
UM, I WANT I'M HERE TO SAY,
UM, TO SUPPORT THIS BILL,
AND I'M GOING TO READ MY TALKING
POINTS BECAUSE OUR
MORE POLISHED REPRESENTATIVE
ISN'T HERE TODAY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T DIMINISH OUR
SINCERITY
IN OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRES PROGRAM
IS A CRITICAL INITIATIVE
AIMED AT REDUCING FIRE RISK IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROGRAM HAS CONTRIBUTED
ALREADY SIGNIFICANTLY
TO EDUCATING CONSUMERS
ON EFFECTIVE MEASURES THEY CAN
TAKE
TO PROTECT THEIR PROPERTIES.
DESPITE THESE SUCCESSES, THERE
ARE ONGOING
CHALLENGES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED.
REVIEWING THE SAFER FROM
WILDFIRES
PROGRAM WILL ALLOW
US TO IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE
IMPROVEMENTS CAN BE MADE.
AND IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
AS WILDFIRE RISK EVOLVES,
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT OUR
PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES KEEP PACE.
THE REVIEW PROCESS WILL ALLOW US
TO INCORPORATE NEW MATERIALS,
TECHNIQUES AND APPROACHES THAT
HAVE PROVEN
TO BE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING
WILDFIRE RISK.
REVIEWING THE SAFER FROM
WILDFIRES
PROGRAM IS A CRUCIAL STEP IN OUR
ONGOING EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE IN CALIFORNIA,
AND BY CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVING
AND UPDATING
OUR WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
STRATEGIES,
WE CAN BETTER PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES
AND AND ENSURE FAIRER INSURER
PRICING FOR HOMEOWNERS WHO
INVEST
IN MAKING THEIR PROPERTIES
SAFER.
I WILL ADD THAT THERE ARE VERY
FEW MANDATORY DISCOUNTS
IN ANY PROPERTY CASUALTY
COVERAGE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRE
DISCOUNTS
ARE AN IMPORTANT SET.
THEY'RE MEANT TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND,
OF COURSE, REWARD THEM FOR A
DISCOUNT.
WE WANT THOSE DISCOUNTS TO BE
TARGETED
AT THE RIGHT MITIGATIONS THAT
ARE GOING TO BE THE MOST
MEANINGFUL
AND HELPFUL TO CONSUMERS.
AND LIKE ANY STUDY OF SCIENCE,
IT'S NOT A ONE AND DONE.
YOU KNOW, THERE WAS CONSIDERABLE
THOUGHT
PUT INTO THE CURRENT
MITIGATIONS,
BUT I THINK FURTHER REVIEW WILL
ONLY PROSPER BY MAKING US
MORE AWARE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MITIGATIONS AVAILABLE.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
UM THANK YOU JOE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING TO
SPEAK ON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE?
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MIC.
THANK YOU.
>> ETHAN NAGLER, MAYOR OF THE
CITY
OF SANTA ROSA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> CLIFTON WILSON ON BEHALF OF
THE MARIN COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT?
UM, SEEING NONE, WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE OVER
TO ANYONE WISHING TO PRESENT IN
OPPOSITION.
>> SHERRY MCCUE, REPRESENTING
THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION
OF DOMESTIC INSURANCE COMPANIES.
WE ARE PLEASED TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION,
THANKS TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
MARK SCOTLAND WITH THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE ALSO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION TO
THE GOOD WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF,
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE ON ENSURING THAT
THE MITIGATION STANDARDS THEY
HAVE ARE
COMPLETE AND TERRIBLY EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU.
>> BUT.
GRACE COPELAND HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA,
ALSO WITHDRAWING OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
>> MARJORIE, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN WOOD COUNCIL.
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN WOOD PRESERVERS
INSTITUTE.
I'M THANKFUL TO THE CHAIR AND
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION?
OKAY.
NOW I'LL MOVE OVER TO THE
MEMBERS.
ANYONE WISHING TO MAKE COMMENTS,
I'LL MOVE IT OVER TO SENATOR
DODD.
YEAH, I APPRECIATE THIS BILL
FROM THE FROM
THE CONTEXT THAT HOPEFULLY,
YOU KNOW,
IN SIX YEARS THAT THE INSURANCE
COMPANY
WILL HAVE A RATE BASE ON
WHICH THEY CAN ACTUALLY DISCOUNT
TO CUSTOMERS THAT DO THE WORK.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, I'VE SAID
THIS
BEFORE IN COMMITTEE HEARINGS,
THIS IS SOMETHING.
BUT, UH, YOU KNOW, RIGHT NOW
WITH,
WITH WITH WHAT'S GOING ON,
IT'S EVERYTHING WE COULD DO JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT INSURANCE IS,
IS WRITTEN, UH, YOU KNOW, HERE.
SO I, I, I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING
THIS BE AN EFFECTIVE MEASURE
THAT WILL ACTUALLY HELP
CONSUMERS DOWN THE LINE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBER WISHING TO
SPEAK.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
>> THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
UM, AS THE DEPARTMENT INDICATED,
THEY ARE OPPOSED TO DOING THIS
OR ARE
NOT GOING TO DO THIS OTHERWISE.
UH, THEY HAVE NOT EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WHAT ABOUT THE PRACTICE?
HAVE THEY INDICATED TO YOU?
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU'RE BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD BECAUSE
YOU THINK THE DEPARTMENT'S NOT
GOING TO DO IT?
WELL, THEY'RE COMMITTED, I KNOW,
TO THE SAFER FROM WILDFIRES
PROGRAM.
UM, SO THIS IS PUTTING SOME
PARAMETERS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN APPROACH THAT IN THE
FUTURE.
SO WE HAVE BEEN OBVIOUSLY IN
COMMUNICATION
WITH THEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK?
ANY OTHER MEMBER?
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND FIRST OF ALL, LET ME JUST,
YOU KNOW,
SAY HOW THANKFUL I AM.
I KNOW WE SPENT SO MANY DAYS
AND HOURS TALKING ABOUT THIS
BILL,
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW,
MY COMMENTS GO TO I THINK WERE
THE GREAT SENATOR WAS HEADED
TOWARDS.
I WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
STILL HAS THE ABILITY TO TO
OVERSEE
THIS AT ANY TIME, RIGHT.
THAT'S HIS AUTHORITY.
SO HE WILL OR SHE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO TO DO AS THEY
DESIRE.
BUT ANYHOW, I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU.
WE DID STREAMLINE IT A LITTLE.
WE BROUGHT IT DOWN TO FIVE.
AND I THINK, AGAIN, THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
OR HAS THE ABILITY TO DO SO
ANYWAYS.
BUT AT LEAST IF WE PUT FIVE
YEARS IN PLACE,
AT LEAST WE KNOW THAT EVERY
TECHNICALLY EVERY, UM,
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER DURING
THEIR
TENURE HAS THE ABILITY TO,
TO, TO REVIEW AND ENFORCE.
SO I WANTED TO ADD ONE MORE
THING
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND SO WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS,
THE REASON IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
ME TO WAIT,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
HAS BEEN WORKING ON IT.
I KNOW THAT BASED ON SOME OF
THE WORK THAT WE DID LAST YEAR,
WE PUT SO MUCH WORK INTO TRYING
TO FIGURE
OUT A SYSTEM WHERE WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER.
AND I DID NOT WANT HIM TO FEEL
THAT HIS WORK OR
ALL OUR COLLECTIVE WORK,
CONSUMER WATCHDOGS,
THE INDUSTRY AND EVERYONE THAT
WORKED ON LAST
YEAR DIDN'T THAT OUR WORK DIDN'T
MATTER.
BUT IT THIS WAY IT GIVES THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
TIME TO WORK ON THOSE
PROCEDURES.
IT GIVES US A COUPLE OF YEARS
TO TO RECONVENE,
ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS AND THEN
FIGURE
OUT IF THERE'S SOMETHING
MISSING.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT, UH,
YOU KNOW,
THINGS CHANGE IN TERMS OF
MITIGATION,
AND HOPEFULLY WE'RE ABLE TO
REVIEW
MITIGATION STANDARDS IN
THE FUTURE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING
WHAT WE CAN FOR CONSUMERS.
AND I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
MIDDLE GROUND.
SO THANK YOU.
UM, IT'S BEEN A LONG,
HARD ROAD TO TO GET TO WHERE
WE'RE AT.
AND THANK YOU TO THE INSURERS
WHO NOW GONE TO NEUTRAL.
SO WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO ASK
MADAM
SECRETARY TO TO CALL THE ROLL.
ANYBODY ARE WILLING TO MAKE A
MOTION HERE.
MOVE BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU.
FILE ITEM 1AB 2416 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONLEY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
RUBIO I.
RUBIO A.
NILO.
ALVARADO, GIL I.
CABALLERO, CORTEZ I.
CORTEZ I.
DODD, I.
OKOBO.
OKOBO I.
501.
WHAT DO WE LOSE?
>> OKAY, WE LOSE SOMEONE.
YEAH, WE DON'T HAVE COPYRIGHT,
BUT WE HAD SIX.
OKAY, GOOD.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A50.
THANK YOU, MR.
COLONY.
WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE MORE
MEMBER,
SO WE'LL KEEP THIS OPEN FOR OUR
SENATOR CABALLERO TO ATTEND.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UM, FOR EVERYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE
ANOTHER PAUSE UNTIL WE HAVE
A FULL,
UM, UH, BODY HERE.
AND SO MISS CABALLERO AND HER
STAFF,
IF YOU ARE HEARING US TODAY,
PLEASE COME AND JOIN US AS SOON
AS YOU CAN.
THANK YOU EVERYONE.
>> OH, THAT'S JUST TO ADD ON.
THE SENATE INSURANCE COMMITTEE
WILL RECONVENE.
WE ARE GOING TO GO OVER TWO
BILLS,
AB 2416 BY CONNOLLY AND AB 2996.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH AB
2416 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY A MOTION BY
CORTESE.
IT'S AT FIVE ZERO.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB 2416 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY.
MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CABALLERO I.
THAT BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO.
WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO AB
2996 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ
ALVARADO.
GILL MADE THE MOTION.
WE'RE AT SIX ZERO.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
AB 2996 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ.
MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO A.
AND.
AND THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU EVERYONE THAT'S
WATCHING AND THAT JOINED
US HERE TODAY IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.